the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from
those who advocated for the superiority
of the white race
i mean no just statistically no is
coming from people who believe that
there's an excuse for violence across
the nation
rooted in america's history of racism
there's one ideology that the left
wishes to ignore
when it is tied to violence we all know
what that ideology is
okay merrick garland who's the new
attorney general yesterday i was
testifying
and he said that the top domestic
violence extremist threat comes from
white supremacists which is kind of an
amazing statement given the fact that
we've seen an uptick in murder across
the nation numbering thousands of
murders across the nation over the
course of the last year
connected to a deeper root belief
in the systemic nature of american
racism we have seen two billion dollars
of damage
done last year alone in the vast spate
of rioting connected to ideology these
were outgrowths of the actual protests
and yet apparently the only threat that
is worth talking about is the white
supremacist
terror threat again you don't have to
download one
to to talk up the other you can talk up
both
but i've noticed that we're not talking
about both we're only talking about one
it happens to be the one that is
responsible yes
for a certain number of murders in the
last year
and we are downplaying the other one
that is responsible for the collapse of
major american cities
here is merrick garland according to an
unclassified summary of the march
intelligence assessment
the two most lethal elements of the
domestic violence extremist threat
are racially or ethnically motivated
violent extremists
and militia violent extremists in the
fbi's view
the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race
okay so that is the greatest domestic
violence threat in america
not just terrorist threat domestic
violence threats
in america okay i
no i mean no just statistically no the
greatest domestic violence threat that
is tied to ideology in america
is not coming from white supremacists
it's coming from people who believe that
there is an excuse for violence across
the nation
rooted in america's history of racism it
is it is it is the group of people
in government in the halls of power
and yes on the ground committing acts of
violence right now committing crimes
who blame that on american racism and
suggest that the violence is justified
because you know what america sort of
deserves it
and and again it's amazing how how
people on the left will actively
downplay this threat because it is so
closely tied to some of the things that
they promote so merrick garland says
don't worry guys we're not focused on
ideology this is not an attempt to crack
down
on ideology we're just focused on
violence purely and specifically
we are focused on violence not
on ideology in america
espousing a hateful ideology is not
unlawful we do not investigate
individuals for their first amended
amendment protected
activities we do not prosecute people
for their beliefs
across the world extremist
or terrorist labels have at times been
affixed
to those perceived as political threats
to the ruling
order but there is no place for
partisanship
in the enforcement of the law
okay so he's saying at least we're going
to preserve free speech in all of this
right that's really what we're going to
do now i have a question do you trust
them to preserve free speech
truly considering that every time there
is a
domestic terrorist who's the white
supremacist the entire media rush to
condemn the entire right
hey do you trust that this
administration is really going to
preserve first amendment rights
i have some trouble believing that they
are interested in preserving first
amendment rights
and first amendment rights do in fact
apply to everyone that apply to blm
protesters the same way they apply to
white supremacists
i hate all of that okay i hate all of
those ideologies
that does not mean that they don't have
rights okay but again
this is there is in a political
motivation
to ignoring one problem here that is
much larger than the other problem in
terms of size and scope
and depth of effect on everyday american
life
and again i just keep pointing this out
the disparity
in what the left is willing to
acknowledge about ideologies that are
closely tied with its own and their
connection to violence
and what they are willing to focus on is
pretty astonishing
to take an example andy mccade now
you'll remember uh you'll remember
andrew mccabe andrew mccabe of course
was uh one of the he was the former fbi
agent who was tied into the russia
investigation and he
engaged in in ridiculous acts that ended
up basically
i believe losing him his pension anyway
andrew mccabe
was on cnn yesterday talking about this
and uh and he said well you know we
still don't know what motivated the
congressional baseball shooting
interesting he brought the other side of
the equation
into it by referring to the shooting of
the congressional baseball practice
and he did it very carefully by saying a
shooting by someone only
who committed a shooting only after he
confirmed
that the players were republican so i
think that reflects the fact that the
fbi still doesn't exactly know what that
shooter was up to they never
really uncovered the sort of detailed
evidence
that laid out a specific plot or an
objective but it is undeniable
that he was targeting republicans
okay again and andy mccabe suggesting
there that the fbi still doesn't
doesn't know what exactly motivated this
i know the fbi knows full well the guy
had a list
in his pocket of republicans he was
shouting this is for health care well he
shot republicans
so yeah we kind of know but the
temptation by folks on the left to
downplay violence
so long as it is linked with their side
continues to astonish
and dismay because that does have some
really
negative impact and i got a uh an email
the other day
from a member of our military so the
military right now is undergoing
all sorts of violent extremist training
uh violent extremist threat training
so that means that they're sat down and
they're put through powerpoint
presentations about the evils of white
supremacy and be on the lookout
for people who are being recruited into
white supremacist groups
and this member of the military raised
his hand and he asked the the training
commanding officer
he asked him okay what about blm and
antifa and the training commanding
officer said
no those are not extremist groups those
are just philosophies
yeah sure how's this for a title
ben shapiro show subscriber destroys
like button with clicks and logic i'd
watch that
make it happen gang